>> Peter Vankevich: OK.
Before we start, I do again
want to do a little shout-out
to our ASL interpreters who
have been doing a super job here
today [applause].
So, it's always important.
All right.
I want to just introduce you to
Gayle Osterberg who is director
of communications at
the Library of Congress.
Doesn't that sound great?
So, Gayle, welcome [applause].
>> Gayle Osterberg: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
You run a very tight ship over
here on the Fiction stage.
Welcome everyone.
It's so nice to see you all.
We spend such a long number of
months preparing for this event,
and it's always so exciting to
be here and to see you all come
out and celebrate books
and reading with us here
at the convention center.
So, thank you.
Thank you for coming and
spending your Saturday with us.
I also want to take a
minute and say thank you
to our many sponsors who not
only make it possible for this
to be a free event, but
just to have the event.
It just wouldn't take
place without all
of their generosity and support.
Many-- Thank you [applause].
Thank you.
Many of them have booths
down on the expo floor.
So if you happen to be down
there and see Wells Fargo,
the Washington Post,
IMLS, NEA, NEH,
many others, tell
them thank you.
That would be so wonderful.
And if you're interested
in donating yourself,
it's very easy, loc.gov/donate.
No contribution is too small
and it will go a long way
to helping us make sure
that we can continue
to have this event each year.
Now, our next guest and I
want to tell you this first
so that you write it down and
remember our book signing is
from 4:30 to 5:30 in line
number 7, so make a note.
She is the best-selling
author of 30 novels,
many telling rich
stories of the south
with wonderful women
protagonists
who are navigating
life's changes.
Her most recent novel, Before
We Were Yours, is a compelling
and heartbreaking story inspired
by actual events that occurred
in Tennessee over three decades
in the early 20th century.
Everyone is reading this book.
How many of you have
read this book?
I posted a picture of
it when I was reading it
at the beach earlier
this summer,
and all of my friends
immediately commented.
And I thought I would share just
a few of them because I think
that they were very on target.
That was one of those
books I wish it didn't end.
This book gave ways to thousands
of children who deserve
to have their story told.
This took a heartbreaking
story and made it something
that I could not put down.
My view is that this writer
not only has revealed something
troubling about our
collective history
but she's also told
us a beautiful
and inspirational story
about second chances.
I loved this book and I can't
wait to hear her talk about it.
Please welcome to the
stage for her debut,
National Book Festival
appearance, Lisa Wingate.
[ Applause ]
>> Lisa Wingate:
Well, good afternoon.
This kind of room is
sort of my dream room,
a room full of book people.
I have been a book nerd
since Ms. [inaudible] told me
in the first grade that I
would be a writer somebody.
And I just believed her because
first grade teachers don't lie.
There's this thing when
you're young and you want
to be a writer and I've been
writing stories all my life.
But there's this thing you dream
of you think you will grow up
and you will become a
writer and it will be
like what you see on TV.
And on TV, writers drive around
in Ferraris and they live
at the beach and they
go in the grocery store
and everybody knows
who they are.
And you never actually
see them writing.
They just go around
being writers.
But you get into this business
and you find out it's not really
like that for most people.
Most people are going
to work long and hard
to achieve even a
full-time living in writing.
It's a tough business.
But you always dream that
you will have that book,
that book that just
blasts out into the world
and takes on a life of its own.
And this book for me has
been that dream book.
It's not my first book.
This is actually novel
number 30 for me.
So, I'm kind of an
example of how
to achieve your dream
in 30 novels or less.
But-- Thank you [applause].
This story, my agent put
the call out on a Wednesday.
By Thursday, 10 of
the biggest publishers
in New York wanted to see it.
By Friday, we had what for
me was a huge preempt offer
on the book if we would sell it
then and not send it to auction.
My agent said I don't
think we should take it.
I think we should let it go to
auction I think will do better.
So, I kind of squeaked out.
OK, if that's what
you think is best.
And those things always happen
on a Friday so that you can fret
about it all weekend,
which I did.
And-- But by Monday, it was
going to auction and it sold
to Random House Valentine,
a division of Random House,
and ended up with
the most amazing crew
of the longtime publishing
professionals
who have worked together for
years and have been fantastic
to this book and never ending
in their support of it.
So, the book came
out a year ago, June.
And the first week it came out,
it landed just a few slots off
of the New York Times list.
And unfortunately, that's
not like horseshoes.
You don't get points
for being close.
So everyone was saying to me,
Lisa, your book is doing great.
But what they weren't
saying was,
but it landed just
off the Times list.
And usually, you figure your
first week, maybe your first
and second week are really
your only chance because that's
when all your presales
come in and whatnot.
So, it didn't make it then.
It didn't make in the end.
We thought-- It was
still steaming along.
We thought maybe July 4th week
because nobody puts out a lot
of their heavy duty books
on the 4th of July weekend.
It didn't make it then.
This book carved its way
onto the New York Times
list eight weeks out,
which hardly ever happens and
it wasn't because Oprah called
or anything like that.
It was just people.
It was just the power of
word of mouth that was people
who read it, who told
someone, who crammed it
into someone's hand in
an airport bookstore,
who told their book group
we should read this.
It was just people who shared.
It was people.
So if you think it doesn't
matter that we still talk
about stories, that we
still talk about things
that impassion us,
things that matter to us,
things that grab us by the
heart and soul, it does.
There is still incredible power
in just the sharing of story.
And if you really think about
it, National Book Festival,
we could have an
international book festival
and we could invite
people from every culture.
And if language were
not a barrier,
we would all have this one
thing in common from a chalet
in France to a city in
America to a village in Africa
that we all process the world
through story in some way.
We all catalog our
history through story.
And so for me, that is
such a magnificent thing
and it's the best thing now.
I'm thrilled we didn't make the
New York Times list our first
week out because there's
no better way for me--
for this dream to have
come true than for the book
to make it eight weeks out
and it has actually
stayed there ever since.
So, whatever else happens--
Thank you [applause].
Whatever else comes
to this book,
it's already been
the dream for me.
I'll answer a few
of the questions
that people ask me
the most about it.
And then whatever you
want to know, I would love
to answer any questions
that you have.
People always ask and
that you always get
in the press interviews
when a book is coming out,
does any of this come
from your own life?
Did you experience any of this?
Is this your family history?
And this story-- And in case
you don't know the story,
it's based around
a piece of history
that was America's
largest adoption scandal
which took place from the '20s
through the '50s in Memphis
under the direction of a
woman named Georgia Tann
who ran the Tennessee
Children's Home Society
and pretty much ran
adoption within Memphis
and within the state of
Tennessee and specialized
in providing children for
the wealthy and the famous,
many Hollywood celebrities,
Joan Crawford,
June Allyson, Dick Powell.
Politicians adopted through her.
The-- While many of the
children were orphans,
many of them were
also just stolen
from poor families
to fill orders.
So, that is the history
this book is wrapped around.
I don't have-- I'm not
close to the history
of it on the adoption side.
There aren't a lot of adoptions
in my family that I'm close to.
My brothers used to try
to tell me I was adopted.
We look so much alike that
there would be teachers,
substitute teachers would look
at me say, you have a brother
in the sixth grade, don't you?
And I hope you're
nothing like him.
So as a little girl not
only is that frightening
but it's not a confidence
builder
to be told you look
like your brothers.
But where I felt the
closest to this story or one
of the places I felt close to
it, because this story is--
because the true history is in
Memphis, it's a river story.
If you know anything
about Memphis,
if you've ever been there,
if you spent time there,
Memphis is a river town.
The river is the heart and
soul and lifeblood of Memphis,
the showboats, the
paddle-wheelers.
That's the identity of Memphis.
And I do know about
life on a river.
As a kid, I grew up
in this little sort
of horseshoe-shaped
1970s neighborhood
where every house sat on
an acre or two or five.
And right through the middle
of this neighborhood ran
this little dirt bottomed
Oklahoma creek.
And it was just a
trickle on a summer day.
A couple times a year when it
really rained, it did come up
and flood some of
the low-lying houses.
But to us kids, that creek
was every river from the Nile
to the Amazon to the Congo in
darkest Africa and, you know,
we were Tarzan and Zorro
and Laura Ingalls Wilder
and Swiss Family Robinson.
And if we had read it in
a book or seen it on TV,
we went down in that creek
and we played it by the hour.
And nobody had to tell us
kids how to make up a story.
We just did it because we were
bored and there was nothing
to do back in those days
unless it was Saturday morning
and there were cartoons on.
And so, we go down that creek.
And about once a week, we
would make up our minds
that we were going to go farther
down that creek than any kid
in the history
of the neighborhood
had ever been before.
And we'd pack a little backpack
and we'd set out in the morning
and we journey and journey
and we'd stop at some point
and have our lunch
and we'd go on.
And we'd go until we thought
we had traveled for miles.
And we would start to tell
each other scary stories
about how far away
from home we were
and maybe we wouldn't
get home before dark,
and maybe our mamas would have
to call the police to come look
for us and kidnappers might
get us and we might need
to defend ourselves
from wild animals.
And we'd get about half
scared and then it would get
to be sort of supper time.
And the thing about that
creek was it had an arbor
of trees over it.
You couldn't tell time of day
down there unless
it was high noon
and the sun was coming
straight down.
You had no cognition
of time of day.
So, it would get toward
evening and a lot of you
in this room probably remember
what happened when it got to be
about supper time
back in those days.
The mama calls, would go
out across the neighborhood.
So, we would be down in the
Congo looking for lost tribes
of men or out on the prairie
with Laura Ingalls Wilder
and we'd hear Laura,
Lisa, Annabeth.
And we would come up out of
that creek and we were still
in someone's backyard
the whole time.
But the thing about it was
because that creek was its own
little world, because it was dug
down into the soil, because
you didn't hear voices,
you didn't hear cars, you
didn't hear people up top,
it was its own universe.
You were not conscious of what
was happening above the banks.
And that is exactly the
life these kids are living
in this story on this
little shanty boat
that their parents built in
the Mississippi River right
up until they dock up in Memphis
and their lives intersect
with what is going on
in Memphis in 1939.
People ask me how did I
come across the true piece
of history Georgia Tann and
the Tennessee Children's
Home Society?
Why did I decide
to write about it?
Why did I put it in a novel?
For me, every story has a
spark and I never know what
that spark is going to be,
but something will come
across my mind from somewhere
just a story someone tells me,
something I read in the
newspaper, a historical marker
when we've stopped to empty
the trash on a family vacation.
I never know, but something
will come across my path
and it just explodes my mind.
And I think why didn't
I know about that?
Do other people not know about?
What more is there to know?
How did that happen?
The spark for this story I came
across completely accidentally.
I had never heard
of it, which is odd
because I've spent quite
a bit of time in Memphis
but nobody had ever come
to me and said, you know,
if you want a great story to
begin to, there was this woman
and she sold all these
thousands of kids into adoptions
and made herself wealthy
and I had never heard of it.
But where I felt closest to it
and where it most exploded
my mind and drove my passion
when I came across the truth
was as a parent because as much
as I love writing and sharing
stories and storytelling
and meeting people and
all of the things that go
with this life of story,
my favorite job was still
being a mom to two little boys.
And as I'm digging into the
true history of Georgia Tann
and the Children's Home Society,
what happened to these kids
who were plucked up out of
their lives through no fault
of their own and dropped
in an orphan house
and they don't know what's
going on, why they're there,
what's happening, there's
no counseling going on,
they literally are in their
lives one day and not the next.
And as I'm studying up on this
after I first heard about it,
I'm thinking of my own kids at
two and four and six and eight,
these two little pieces of my
heart and how innocent they were
and how helpless they were.
And what if-- how would
they have handled something
like this.
And I'm thinking of myself
as a parent, you know,
what if one day someone took my
kids and I couldn't find them
and I couldn't help them
and I couldn't get to them
and I maybe didn't even
ever know where they were
and perhaps I never
saw them again.
What would that be like?
And to just put you in that
head space a little bit,
imagine with me now, it's the
'20s through the '50s some time,
you are a person who desperately
wants to be a parent.
You come from a culture
where within about a year
of the wedding, everybody
has babies,
it's just it's what's done,
not less than nine
months from the wedding.
My grandmother's first baby
was born nine months to the day
and we came that close to
being the town's scandal.
But it never happens for you.
And you maybe apply
to adopt maybe
through your Catholic orphanage
or your children's home
in the town or children services
or whatever is around you.
And maybe because you have
a divorce in your history,
maybe just because you're older
by that time, maybe because you
and your husband are different
religions, for whatever reason,
there's never a child for you.
You get to a certain age.
It becomes clear there never
will be a child for you.
And then all of the
sudden, you hear--
maybe you hear it from a
friend, maybe you read about it
in a newspaper, maybe you open
your Saturday evening post
in 1930 and there's this big
splashy article called the
baby market.
And it is about this place where
you can go and you're going
to be able to make that
dream happen just like that.
And not only that, you're going
to be able to pick hair color,
eye color, age, gender,
one child or two,
would you like them to look
alike or maybe one that looks
like your husband and
one who looks like you.
I mean, it sounds like
science fiction, doesn't it?
Little Stepford children all
made to order just the ages
and colorings and everything
that somebody wants.
But it's the '20s
through the '50s.
So, these are not
robot children.
They're real children.
And while some of them really
are orphans who need homes,
the dark side of this
history is where the rest
of them are coming from.
And to put you in that
head space a little bit,
imagine the other
side of the story.
You are a parent who's
down on your luck.
It's maybe the depression
and you've lost your farm,
dad's lost his job,
maybe dad has died and--
or ran out and left the family
and you're a woman with a bunch
of kids to take care of,
or maybe you're just a young
girl who's gotten yourself
in trouble with a man
who will not marry you.
But for whatever reason, you're
desperate, you're hungry,
you need medical
care or something.
You go to a free milk and
bread clinic, a doctor's office
that advertises care for
people who can't pay, whatever.
The people there are
very nice to you.
They tell you they will
solve all your problems.
They want you to sign a few
forms which you maybe can
or can't read because you
quite well may be illiterate.
You think all your problems
are solved when you live there.
What you don't realize is that
you have just been spotted
by a doctor, a nurse, a worker
in an orphanage,
a police officer.
You have just crossed
the radar of Georgia Tann
and the Tennessee
Children's Home Society.
And it is very likely that
someday soon, you will turn
around and your children
will be gone.
And if you even know
what happens to them,
if you can muster the resources
to go to court and try to fight
for them, you will simply
be told they have been given
to people who can give
them much more than you can
and you will not be
getting them back.
That is the startling
reality of what happened,
all these decades in Memphis.
When I started to dig into
it, I had questions of course
as you probably do, how could
something like this happen,
how could it be allowed to go
on, why didn't people stop it,
and that was really the
basis for starting the novel.
I wanted to-- I found
that it hadn't been talked
about very much.
I found that the state of
Tennessee had worked very hard
and a lot of people in powerful
positions around the country
who were in some way tied
to these adoptions had
worked very hard to quiet it
down after the scandal
finally broke.
I wanted to know what
happened to these families
and what became of them and
how she got away with this.
How did I come across it?
Completely by accident.
I was up late working one night
and had left the TV playing
but I turned off the sound
because it just gets lonesome.
When you know you're pulling
deadline, you're going to be
up all night and even the dog
gives up on you and goes to bed.
It just gets lonely.
So about 2 in the morning,
Discovery Channel's
deadly women cycled on
and it was an episode
called Above the Law.
And it was about people who,
because of their connections,
were able to commit
heinous crimes
and never been prosecuted.
And at that point, it was a
segment showing this big white
house and the front room was
full of babies and bassinets
and I just thought, what
in the world is this about?
And that was my introduction
to the history
that became the topic
for this book.
As I was doing the research, I
came across the fact that some
of these kids were stolen
from camps on the river,
that these people who lived in--
they lived in the shanty boat
on the river which
there were tens
of thousands living the shanty
boat life during the depression
and before and after
and it seemed
like such a fascinating life.
And I started to hear the voices
of these five little
kids growing up,
these little stairstep
siblings growing up on the river
and in particular the voice of
the oldest girl Rill who's 12
when the story starts.
And this is what she
experiences as in reality.
It's something completely
random that brings these kids
across the radar of Georgia Tann
and the Tennessee
Children's Home Society.
In the novel, it's because
Queenie, the mother,
is giving birth to what is
expected to be child number six
in this little shanty boat
family and there are problems
with the birth and that
necessitates a trip
to the hospital which in Memphis
at that time was all it took
to bring you across the radar.
This is what happens in the
morning when Rill is waking
up after being left to care
for the younger children.
Chapter 12, Rill Foss
1939, in my dreams,
we're free on the river.
The Model T engine
Briny fixed to the back
of the boat drives
us upwater easy,
like we haven't got
any weight at all.
Queenie sits up top of the cabin
like she's riding an elephant.
Her head's tossed back,
her hair flowing out from
under her feathery red hat.
She's singing a song she
learned from an old-Irishman
in one of the shanty camps.
Well, ain't she pretty
as a queen?
Briny asks me.
The sun is warm and
the song sparrows sing
and the fat bass jump
out of the water.
A flock of white pelicans flies
over in a big old arrow
shape pointing north,
which means we got the whole
summer still ahead of us.
There's not a paddle-wheeler
or a flatboat or a tug
or old barge anywhere in sight.
The river is ours.
It's only ours.
Well, and what's that make
you, Briny asks me in my dream.
Princess Rill of Kingdom
Arcadia, I shout out.
And I know I am the
luckiest little girl
in the whole wide world.
They're in a better place to
be than our Kingdom Arcadia.
Briny sets a honeysuckle
flower crown on my head
and he makes me a princess
for real just like the kings
in all my storybooks did.
In the morning, when I
wake from that dream,
there's still a sweet
taste in my mouth.
It lasts until I open my eyes
and think about why my brothers
and sisters and me are
all five in Queenie
and Briny's big bed together.
We're flopped out
across the mattress
like a fisherman's sketch
all sweaty and slick.
Queenie is not here.
It barely gets through my head
before I know what's pulled me
from my dream.
My heart jumps up and
I jump up with it,
pulling one of Queenie shawls
over my nightgown while
I cross the shanty floor.
It's old Zede on the
other side of the door,
old Zede who's always been
like a granddaddy to all of us.
But even through the
window glass this morning,
I can see that his
white-whiskered face is long
and sad.
My gut pulls tight
like a slipknot
as I open the shanty door.
Zede's hand feels
heavy on my shoulder.
It's meant for a comfort, but
I want to run away from it.
I want to scat off
somewhere down the riverbank,
my feet flying so fast,
they barely leave tracks
in the washed-up sand.
Tears shove up my neck
and I swallow hard.
Queenie's babies didn't
make it out, Zede says.
Something inside me
dies, a little brother
or a sister I was planning to
hold like a new china doll.
Not either one of them, I ask.
The doc said no, couldn't
save neither one of them.
Said it wouldn't of made no
matter if'n Briny got your mom
into the hospital sooner.
The babies just wasn't meant
for this world, that's all.
I shake my head hard, trying to
wick those words out of my ears
like water after a swim.
That can't be true.
Not in Kingdom Arcadia.
The river is our magic.
Briny always promised
it'll take care of us.
Well, but what'd
Briny say, I ask.
He's pretty broke up about it.
I left him there at the
hospital with your mama.
They got some papers
to sign and whatnot.
The docs hadn't told her
about losing the babies yet.
Reckon Briny will when
she's woke up good.
She'll be all right,
the doc said.
She'll be all right.
I hear it again in my head,
but I know it ain't true.
Nothing makes Queenie happier
than a brand-new,
sweet baby to cuddle.
She's birthed all five of us
without hardly more
than a whimper.
How could she have
lost both of these two?
Queenie ain't going
to be all right.
Not after this [applause].
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So in the story as in life, it's
that one little random thing,
the fact that Queenie goes
into labor near Memphis,
the fact they dock up there,
the fact that these babies
can't be delivered on the boat.
One of the things that's
happened since the book came
out I've heard from a lot
of people whose families
really are tied
into the Tennessee
Children's Home Society
who were either adoptees or
family members on the birth side
who lost children to Georgia
Tann or who are descendants
of one side or the other.
And, you know, the
ways these kids came
into those hands are
so completely random.
One of the things I've learned--
People always ask you what's
your takeaway from a book
or what do you hope other
people will takeaway.
One of the things I learned
now is learned something
from the characters in the book
which is weird because they come
out of your head, you know,
so how do they know things
that you kind of don't know.
But I always learn
something them.
And one of the things that that
I learned from the characters
in this story comes from
the modern day character
because the story is
told in two parts.
So, the modern day part is
told through the eyes of Avery,
this 30-year-old daughter
of a political dynasty,
senator's daughter in
Aiken, South Carolina
which interestingly enough
I wrote this book right
between elections.
Nobody cared about politics.
So now, everybody wants
to know, are they supposed
to be these people
or those people.
No, they're not any
people that we're talking
about in politics today.
But there's something
Avery says as she's digging
into the Tennessee
Children's Home Society
and how her family might
be connected to it.
Her main fear is just was her
family in any way involved
in the cover up, you
know, were they involved,
were they culpable in
letting this go on?
Does she bear the sins
of past generations?
And she says to herself
as she's been giving kind
of a nice answer about
what may have happened.
She says to herself, it's the
things you want to believe
that you need to look at
the most closely of all.
And now as my lesson to
me, I think in this book is
that those things that I
want to believe, those things
that fall easy on my ear, and
they taste sweet on my tongue
and they fit with everything
that's convenient for me,
I need to dig into those things.
I need to be bold enough
and true enough to dig
into those things and
think is this really true,
is this really plausible.
Thousands of people had this
going on right under their nose.
It was not quiet.
These kids were advertised
in the newspaper
as perfect Christmas presents.
People knew you could
get a baby in Tennessee
when you couldn't get
one anywhere else.
People knew that thousands of
kids were being sent out state
and they just believed
what was easy to believe
because they didn't want to
confront what might be true.
So, that was my lesson to me.
I'll finish up with kind of
a fun story and then I'm--
I want to take any
questions you have.
So in a book, you never know
with the research what
will be tough to research.
And it's never what you think.
So in this book, one of the
tough things was just propulsion
on the river, how are
the boats getting around,
because it's the end of
the steam era, it's--
we're almost to World War
II, gasoline is getting big.
And I needed them to
have a motorized skiff,
a little jon boat type
of thing with a motor
so they can get Queenie
across water to the hospital
and so they can go up current
in the Mississippi
River and whatnot.
And so, I asked my two little,
not little anymore,
fishermen I raised.
What kind of a motor would
be on a jon boat in 1939?
And surprisingly, they
could not tell me that.
So, I did a little research
and I found this one
that was called a water witch.
And I like that, water witch.
I just thought that sounded
powerful and kind of antique
and it was sold in the series
catalog, that water witch.
So, I put a water witch on
the back of Zede's boat,
and they use it to take Queenie
across water and whatnot.
And so it turns out
as I'm working,
a water witch is the hardest
kind of motor to research
in the entire world
as far as I can tell.
I can't found out how fast can
it go, how do you start it,
how do you steer it,
can it go up current
in the Mississippi river.
I can't find out anything.
So, I even go to the motor
museum/convenient store
in Hot Springs, Arkansas to
see if I can see a water witch.
I can't find one.
So, I do what you do
when you're a writer
and you don't really want
to give up your water witch.
I-- You just fudge it.
So instead of saying how
they start the water witch,
you say something like, and
the motor roared to life.
So, I do that.
I send it in.
It's an editorial.
People in-- Editors in New York
really don't know how you start
a water witch either in 1939.
So, it's all going fine.
I go for a writer's
weekend with my favorite--
one of my favorite writer
friends, Judy Christie,
and we're down on Caddo Lake
in Texas and it's a beautiful.
So, we're out on the porch
and Judy is very organized.
So, she's got our
time all divided up.
In this hour, we're going to
brainstorm this book plot.
In this hour, we're going
to talk about the bookmark.
And in this-- So, she's
got our day lined out.
Meanwhile, in a cabin next
door, Sam the fisherman is bored
because it's the
middle of the day.
It's too hot to fish.
So, we're out on our deck.
Sam sat on his deck.
Y'all come on over,
I've got iced tea.
All right.
Well, Sam, we're working.
We'll get over there later.
We go out on the dock.
Sam is out on his dock.
Y'all come over, I've got a
swing and it's shady over here.
So, this goes on the whole trip.
And by the end of the trip, Judy
says, look, Lisa, we have to go
over and see Sam's cabin
because we don't want
to hurt his feelings.
So, we go and I walk into this
place and I have my iPhone,
and I am like a photographer
at a Paris fashion shoot.
Because remember, I have
raised little fishermen.
I want to show them what
kind of a shack they can have
if they stay in college
[laughter]
because this is a
fisherman's shack deluxe.
The cabin-- The handles
are little bobbers,
little red and white bobbers.
The lamps are fishing poles.
The shades are fishing hats.
The toilet paper is
on a fishing reel.
The toilet seat is clear Lucite
with fishing lures
embedded in it.
So, I take all these pictures.
I turn to head out and
there in the bay window
that overlooks the
lake is Sam's big desk.
And right beside the
desk is this motor
on a stand all nicely repainted.
And I get a little
closer and I see the W.
And I get a little closer
and I look at Sam and I say,
is that a water witch?
And Sam says, yes, that's
my 1939 fully restored water
witch [laughter].
So, I take two lessons from that
because I believe everything
in life comes with a lesson.
One is that never give
up on your research
because you never know when it's
just going to fall in your lap.
And secondly, you should
never ignore your neighbors.
[ Applause ]
So, questions?
What else-- What can I
tell you about the story?
>> Hi. I was lucky enough to
get an advance copy of the book
and loved it, but was
very compelled to it
because my grandmother was
actually put in an orphanage
when her father was killed
in an automobile accident
and her mother could
not care for five kids.
So, I was wondering if you
had discovered other incidence
or have heard of other incidence
similar to the one in Tennessee
because my grandmother lived
in South Carolina at that time.
So, I'm just wondering if this
has brought out more history
that you have perhaps come
across that you didn't
know about.
>> Lisa Wingate: Yes.
So, has it brought
out more history
where there are other
places where this went on?
There certainly were.
In fact, not too far from
there in Augusta, Georgia,
there was a lawyer who was kind
of doing the same
thing even afterward.
And even in recent
times, there are states
that have their adoption
laws so loosely regulated.
It's very easy to bring
in a woman from Russia
or some other country and call
her a resident of the state
and then sell her baby into a
very expensive private adoption.
So, similar things still go on.
There were other orphanages
also where this kind
of thing was going on.
Some of it was a
creature of the time.
Some of it definitely
was a creature
of some social engineering.
The idea-- Georgia Tann could
say right out in public,
in the newspaper articles
things like if you take them
from these cows and these
breeders and you place them
with people of high type and
surround them with beauty
and culture, they can become
anything you want them to be.
She purported the children as
blank slates and basically,
you know, that they--
people could mold them
into anything they wanted.
And it was a recipe
for very bad adoptions
because a child is
not a blank slate.
Even a baby is not
a blank slate.
And certainly a five, six,
seven year-old who knows that he
or she has a family
is not a blank slate.
So in some ways, yes, it was
a creature of a time period
when people really had no
other options sometimes
but to leave a child
in an orphanage.
And the idea was sort of that
the parents were almost--
or that the adoptive families
or the families who took them
in were almost doing them
a favor by taking them
in which sounds like you
have some of that history
in your family and
probably looked at the story
in a different way
because of that.
>> Thank you.
>> Lisa Wingate: People have
asked me a lot how she got away
with it.
And really, she was not someone
anyone would have suspected.
Part of the reason she got away
with it is because she came
from the upper crust of society.
She was a judge's daughter.
She drove around in a limousine.
She lived in a mansion.
She was not anyone, anyone
would have suspected of needing
or wanting to be
selling children.
Yes?
>> Hi. So, this is more of a
question about craft I guess.
But you're such a
prolific writer.
I guess I wanted to hear some
of your insights about kind
of the hard work that it takes
to, you know, produce each book
from start to finish and
what you've kind of learned
over the years about the
process side of things.
>> Lisa Wingate: OK,
so the writing process.
Writing process is a
tough thing because it's--
so individual is
different for everybody.
And so, I always feel a
little bit like when I talk
about writing process,
I want to first say,
but if this isn't
the way you do it,
that's fine because
there is no right way.
For me, I'm not an
advanced plotter so much.
I have a rough three-act
structure
of the story in my mind.
And I always start out--
When I have a piece of truth
that I want to talk
about, I always start
out with just thinking
who would tell that story,
what eyes are you going to
look at the story through.
And then, I have sort of a
rough three-act structure
that comes partly
just from imagination
and partly from the research.
And if you're curious
about that, there's--
I used to teach a class in
three-act structure and--
because every story is
structured that way.
And if you're curious about
it, you can go to my website
which is [inaudible], but
the materials are on there.
And that's helpful to me.
But a lot of the story is going
to develop out of the research,
out of the time as
I'm writing it.
Sometimes, I will
literarily quit
for the day thinking one thing
will happen and I'll wake
up in the morning with
something else in mind.
So, I never know.
I write a certain
amount everyday.
Different people are different.
But if I sat around and waited
to-- until I felt inspired or--
yeah, I just would never write.
I mean, for me, it's
a little like sitting
down everyday to
take the ACT test.
It's just hard.
And I think-- And what foils
most people is finding some kind
of a groove you can get into.
You know, we all have our--
we're kind of like
baseball players.
You know, different ones
do different things,
kind of get in the
groove to get up to bat.
And I think for a writer, that's
one of the most valuable things.
You just find what gets you
in your groove and then figure
out how you're going to get back
in the groove day
after day after day.
I'm a fairly fast writer.
I can turn out a book in four
or five months and manuscript.
And, you know, that's
not right for everybody,
but it's what works for me.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. I actually
have two questions.
One, what are you
working on now?
And then in your research,
did you have an opportunity
to meet anyone from the
Children's Home or descendants
of people who had
been in the home?
>> Lisa Wingate: OK.
So, what am I working on now?
I am working on a new book.
I just-- Just recently, I
had actually kind of started
and finished the manuscript
about something I had in mind
for a while to write about.
And then few months ago,
history lightning struck again.
And I just came across another
piece of history and thought,
oh, you know, this is really the
story I would want to do next.
I feel such a passion
for this story.
And I would tell you about
it except I'm not allowed to.
But every story has its own--
you know, it's the same process.
It's discovering the history
and how to make it work
within the story and I
am so excited to bring
to light this piece of history
because it's another one
that involved so many people.
I'm like how do people
not know about this?
What was the second question?
>> Did you have an opportunity
in your research to meet any
of the people who
have been in the home
or descendants of those?
>> Lisa Wingate: To
meet the real people.
So, yes. So, I had met a couple
and interviewed them
when I started out.
And it was odd because neither
one of them, they were OK
to talk to me but they
didn't want me using their
name anywhere.
In other words, they
didn't want to be outed
as having been adopted from
the Tennessee Children's
Home Society.
So, the book comes out.
I start hearing from adoptees
and families of adoptees
and families who are still
searching for family members
that they've never found.
And then people start asking me,
would you ever get
a reunion together
of people who are connected to?
So last summer of last--
this past June, I had
an event in Memphis.
And so, we did have a
reunion and got about 25
of them together and they
ran the gamut from people
who were adopted as babies,
people who were old enough
to remember, four daughters
of a woman who was stolen
with her six siblings
out of the front yard
of their little shanty house.
So, it was quite an experience
and we ended up doing a couple
of presentations where they
got on panels and talked
about their experience.
And not many of them had
reunited with family and things.
And so, it was an
amazing experience.
Oh, I think we're
on last question.
We got just a couple
more minutes.
>> Well, I was just going to ask
you about that my mother was one
of the children from the
Memphis Children's Home.
And she was constantly trying
to find her mother every
day before she passed away.
So, you were just saying
that there are stories
of reconciliation between
children who were adopted
and then were able to
reunite with their parents.
Can you say what that was like?
>> Lisa Wingate: There are many.
There was a woman in Memphis,
Denny Glad [assumed spelling],
who is kind of like the Trent
Turner character in the book
who helped a lot of
adoptees find their paperwork
and find their families.
One of the things
that made it hard was
that so much paperwork
was altered.
So a lot of times
when people got--
they fought for years
to get the records open
because Tennessee had
sealed all the records.
Once they did, a lot of times
the records were incorrect
and didn't help.
So, Denny Glad was instrumental,
not only getting the
paperwork opened,
but in helping people read
between the lines and going
around and checking court docket
books and all kinds of things.
And she did help reunite many
who found their birth families.
Often with wonderful results,
sometimes not, you know.
It just depends.
And there are many who--
like your mother, who--
they'll just never know.
That's one of the reasons
why everybody doesn't reunite
in the novel because I felt like
it wasn't fair because there are
so many people who
will have to just live
with those questions
all their lives.
>> OK. Thank you.
>> Lisa Wingate OK.
Yes?
>> Yes. I was wondering, I
have noted some timeliness
of your book subject to
current events and wonder
if you saw an increase in sales
after the children
were separated
from their parents
at the border.
>> Lisa Wingate: So,
many people-- Yes.
Many people have equated
what was happening
with Tennessee Children's Home
Society with the children--
the border crisis
for the children.
Oddly, that was coming up in
June right as I was meeting
with these people whose life
experience is tied into this,
and what I learned
from them is--
and even the children and
grandchildren of these people,
what happens to children, the
damage done to children travels
down through the generations.
The people-- The descendants
will tell you this experience.
Even people who were
adopted as babies
and had wonderful
adoptive parents,
they will tell you this
experience being tied
into Georgia Tann and the
Tennessee Children's Home
Society and what happened
informed everything
about my mother's
life or everything
about my grandmother's life.
And so, you know, I think, yeah,
the lesson to learn from it is
that whatever adult
battles are going on,
children should never
pay the price for them
because that goes
down [applause].
One minute.
>> I was wondering about the
famous people, all the people
that had adopted these--
what ever happened to--
or do they have to give the map.
I mean, when it was found
out that they had adopted these
children, it must have been hard
for the children as well.
And what ever happened
to them, were they ever--
I mean, is it criminal
or what happened?
>> Lisa Wingate: Nobody
was ever prosecuted.
Georgia Tann died as the
scandal was breaking.
So, she was not prosecuted.
But that made it very easy
for everyone to just say, oh,
it was just her and she
had everybody fooled
because she was dead
at that point.
So, you know, she was
a very easy scapegoat.
No children were sent back
to their birth families.
Of the 22 who were in custody
of the Tennessee Children's
Home Society at the end
when the scandal broke,
only two were given
to their birth family, back
to their birth families
and the rest were adopted out.
>> What about June Allyson and--
>> Lisa Wingate: They-- None of
those children were sent back
to their birth families.
The records were quickly and
quietly sealed and life went on.
>> And we only know now
that that's what happened.
I mean, did anyone know at
the time that June Allyson
and Joan Crawford had
adopted these children or?
>> Lisa Wingate: You know,
some of them did in adult life,
go back and find their birth
families back in Tennessee.
And not all of the
children were stolen.
A lot of them were children who
had been given up by families,
who couldn't raise
them or whatever.
>> And so, there was no
embarrassment for June--
for these famous people?
>> Lisa Wingate: No.
It was in the press a lot,
but they just all said our
adoption was legitimate
and we didn't pay anything but
the normal fees and that was it.
>> Thank you.
>> Lisa Wingate:
Thank you [applause].